في الاثناء نقلت مصادر غربيه عن مسؤول
رفيع في البيت الابيض قوله ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن عبر لقاده مجموعه الدول
السابعه المجتمعين في روشيما عن دعمه
لمبادره مشتركه لتدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات من الجيل الرابع
من ضمنها طائرات اف 16 وكان صحيفه واشنطن
بوست الامريكيه نقلت عن مصادر مطلعه ان
اداره بايدن اشارت الى الحلفاء الاوروبيين
في الاسابيع الاخيره بان الولايات المتحده
لن تعرقل تسليم اوكرانيا طائرات اف 16
وفي اول رد فعل على الموقف الامريكي قال
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسونا كنا
بلاده ستعمل مع الولايات المتحده وهولندا
وبلجيكا والدنمارك لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالقدره الجويه القتاليه التي تحتاجها
ورحب سوناك بالاعلان عن ان الولايات
المتحده ستوافق على تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على طائرات اف 16